[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yay
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
welcome to gearbox university where
inquisitive minds encounter compelling
opportunities
at gearbox university our aim is to
broaden your intellectual horizons and
enrich your global perspective
gearbox university was founded in 1999
just 15 years after this 80s orientation
video was made
we offer numerous degrees across a
multitude of fields including
sociopathology supply chain management
and storytelling with a european
sounding accent
gearbox university comprises three
unique colleges that will place you on
whichever path to success is right for
you at the college of gearbox software
we can shape you into the looting
shooting vault hunter you've always
believed you could be at the college of
gearbox publishing we offer advanced
degrees in norse mythology projectile
meteorology
or regular meteorology you can even
write your thesis on the deification of
gravity
finally there's the college of whatever
the hell else we're doing with
specialties in badass bunkernomics
history of magic enlarged vehicle
maneuvering and yes even hollywood
filmmaking did you hear we're making a
borderlands movie it's true let's learn
more about all the innovative
opportunities you can find at gearbox
university dynamic pioneering
groundbreaking
[Music]
oh
[Music]
good
hey everybody if you don't know me i'm
randy pitchford
the founder of the gearbox entertainment
company and executive producer of the
borderlands franchise and all of the
great games that we do at gearbox i am
right now on the set of the borderlands
motion picture in development in
production we're shooting
this is a live soundstage and i thought
since i'm here wouldn't it be cool if i
walk you around a little bit and show
you some of the cool stuff that we're
doing
let me let me walk you this way this is
a live set there's guys working on the
movie right now in real time
we've been
everywhere we've been
in the caves of the caustic caverns
we've been uh
in the in the desert
in the sand quarries we've been in the
stone quarries doing all kinds of
amazing stuff
actually look uh this is let me hey
hey eli can i drive you for a second yes
this is eli roth our director
hey everybody uh this is uh e3 these are
gamers and you got you've got edgar i
know we have so much he doesn't exist in
the game but he exists in the movie in
real life it's edgar ramirez well edgar
ramirez's character atlas exists
hypothetically in the game we've never
met him before in in the game or in real
life meeting atlas for the first time in
this movie story i'm so stoked that
you're here doing this thank you man i'm
very very happy yeah this is gonna be a
vlog congratulations oh thanks you know
look i feel like we're just getting
started the whole point is to entertain
people and
this movie that eli's making it's i mean
it's underneath i mean we haven't
i don't want to say what we're filming
but it's lots of blood lots of gods it's
totally bonkers but it's also very
borderlands i have learned how to how to
turn up how to twirl a vlad off you know
what i think we should let me show this
yeah we can show that this is this is
the start one this is this isn't this is
video game fans will recognize this is
the infinity it's a vlad off infinity
and uh you've got pretty good a tour
like well they have ones that actually
you know this one is light so i could
really learn because i don't want to
i don't want to smash a real one but
kate's amazing she's like she can side
twirl she can double twirl that's right
you know she can do the front twirl
isn't it unbelievable how she's brought
lily to life i can't wait for you to see
like why is a god i saw you know
everyone thinks of kate from blue
jasmine or carol all the things she's
done and how's the clock in this wall is
i saw how unbelievably funny she was and
i noticed that she brought out the great
dramatic acting in jack black and jack
brought out the great comedy in cape she
was so into it she wants to really you
know understand it from the inside out
like what are the powers where did they
come it's a while to watch her walk like
that blew my mind she's totally done it
we want to make a real great science
fiction movie we don't want to make just
make a great video game adaptation mode
you just have to make a great sci-fi
movie period and it's it's really come
to life so for borderlands fans who uh
play the video game if you have people
in your lives that if that you want to
introduce the borderlands but aren't
going to play the game with you this
movie's how you do it you can bring your
your family your loved ones bring them
to the movie we want to introduce them
to borderlands they're going to love it
we want this to be like a gateway drug
for the non borderlands fans i mean look
the thing is the great thing about the
game is there's so much to it that you
know you're telling 80 hours of story
every time i mean people people can live
in the world so we have to create a
different experience and the experience
has to be thrilling in a different way
and exciting of all the things that the
fans love easily the best cast i've ever
worked with but like just a world-class
cast of actors that all came in just to
come in and play and everyone is so into
their characters like did we see where
florian's playing creed florian is
killing ariana is tiny tiner
[Music]
i think he's really going to surprise
people i think kevin's over there
actually and i know lisa is uh trying to
get a shot
all right come with me guys come with me
i'm gonna see if i can find ari and uh
one of the producers and emmy uh the our
odds are legendary hey ari
can i interrupt you man guys th this
this is uh emmy and ari from ride
productions uh ari arrad has made a
whole bunch of awesome movies uh you're
probably familiar with the r ads from
marvel right because avi arad was the
founder and ceo of marvel studios and
they created a movie called spider-man
and then uh iron man i believe you're
the executive producer i watched that
one you worked on and then uh and then
the x-men and then the avengers and you
know
i think it's gone from there these are
the most successful movies of all time
uh for comic books and
the pitch you gave me was
hey that was cool we figured it out with
comic books uh we think that video games
are the next frontier of this and we
think borderlands is the perfect video
game and you and and you were really
flattering and and how how was idea i
was kind of uh it's kind of a jerk
wasn't it you made us work for it
you made us work for it but you were
right you were right well you have to
understand like we get hit up from
hollywood people all the time and it's a
different world like what we have to do
to make video games is a completely
different skill set than what you care
about in making these incredible films
and i i didn't want i wanted to make
sure that if we were going to partner
with somebody on the film side that it
was
it was with people that cared about our
universe cared about our fans uh and
cared about the character and the worlds
that we created and was going to
actually develop it not just a lot of
these guys will collect options and just
throw it in studios just see where they
can get business done
and you i mean i i probably beat you up
for like two years plus people oh yeah
we called it dating for two years
exactly i remember you remember we were
dating for years yes and uh but we we
did a deal in that and it's been a long
road yeah but you know we're here and
we're psyched and it's really it's been
worth it you know like
it feels like we used that time pretty
well i can't i can't believe it
and we're really proud of where we're at
it's uh it's it's pretty amazing so
we're about we're more than halfway done
oh yeah with the shooting yeah yeah well
we're uh we're about two thirds of the
way down oh look at this
we have a really funny shot
oh yeah with the trash we should be
shooting it behind the scenes i i i i
was told that we don't think we can give
it away but i think that for him anyways
for our behind the scenes we should get
it
so um i'll tell you what you guys um
this is eli this is alright oh don't
look that way you can't no no this way
look at this
[Music]
we can't show yes i don't wanna okay so
guys uh it's gonna be an amazing e3 um
uh borderlands the film is gonna be
absolutely incredible uh
we've got some cool stuff to show you i
know some of you are interested in
seeing more about the uh the new game
that we that we have announced and
learning more from gearbox publishing so
you're going to get all that uh i wish i
could be there in person but since we're
digital we're going to do it this way
thank you guys and i'll catch you later
cheers
among the many innovative courses
offered by gearbox university make sure
you check out borderlands science by
solving the puzzles you can contribute
to real world research studying the
human gut microbiome for you freshmen in
the audience here's our leading
scientist mayam bialik by playing
borderlands 3 you can contribute to
real-world scientific research that
helps real people you'll be directly
helping our scientists organize and
compare this do-do i'm the conductor of
the poop train
with borderlands science you too can be
the conductor of the poop train and
while you'll reap in-game rewards when
you play the real reward is knowing that
you're making the world a better place
gearbox university we're not even
charging tuition for this
[Music]
the homeworld game started
in the mid 90s it would be the first
ever truly 3d rts
so that was a big deal in you know the
late 90s
fate
it soars on the wind
it rises from the grave
it stalks the ocean floor
you cannot hide from fate
but you can
make your own
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
suckers
[Music]
a quick question we're not talking about
yet right
that is correct it's my favorite hi i'm
kayla belmore and i'm senior producer
around tiny tina's wonderlands
so what's really unique about
wonderland's is it's a looter shooter
which is you know pretty classic for
gearbox software but for the first time
ever we're setting it in a brand new
fantasy environment even though it's
inspired by some of uh the content we've
made before with assault on dragons keep
a fan favorite roll for initiative
it's a completely stand-alone plot new
set of characters with some nods to the
past but if you've never played a
borderlands game before you can
absolutely jump right in and enjoy it
just as much
[Music]
because we're absolutely excited to talk
about all of our new enemy types uh so
that is one of our wyvern enemies you
will absolutely be fighting them they're
not your average wyvern so of course
we've got goblins you definitely can't
have a fantasy game without goblins but
again
we like to make them our own thank you
so much everybody i hope that you are as
stoked as we are about tiny tina's
wonderlands follow us on our social
channels to find out the latest and
greatest news enjoy the rest of the show
[Music]
this franchise been around for so long
here we are years later
and we keep looking at like well
homeworld three
this has to happen
the giants have come to midgard and you
have been chosen by the gods to protect
this brain
but your first task is to find some new
clothes that aren't
droppedy
your tribe's journey starts in the
wilderness hunt down pets gather rare
resources and explore the untamed world
once you've plundered all you can carry
return to your village and use those
resources to forge viking worthy gear
you must protect the seed of yggdrasil
at all costs or this world and
everything in it will be destroyed
forever so take heed
the help things rise when the sun sets
destroy these dark spirits before they
destroy the seed
each victorious night makes way for a
new day to venture into new lands
live to greater heights and face fiercer
creatures
and with great risk comes great rewards
but be careful you're little used to
midgard squashed by a troll
craft legendary weapons build deadly
defenses
and grow the strength of your tribe
because those giants are on their way
and it's time for us to end their path
of destruction
let's show them our might
is greater than their height
as the saying goes
valhalla
can't wait
hello everyone my name is joanne moroda
i'm the creative director at norrisville
we're just under two months away from
finally launching our upcoming ten
player co-op action rpg drives a midgard
and deliver it to you on july 27th on
ps5 ps4 and steam
in tribes of midgard you play as an inor
a glorious viking hero that's been
returned to midgard in order to protect
the seed of victor seal the world tree
every time you start a new run you would
want to go out and explore this new
world gather some resources fight
enemies and return to your village in
order to craft better equipment and
tools to help you survive you can also
upgrade and fortify your village because
each night creatures from hell will
emerge from the depth to attack your
tree
make it through the night to go back out
to raid enemy camps dwell in caves take
part in events go on quests build
anywhere and of course loot complex
items to gain experience and level up
your viking we now have eight classes in
the game each with their own abilities
specificities and play style
as you can experience you level up to
unlock even more skills which you can
then combine with dozens of runes for
over-the-top results
but those nightly creatures aren't even
your biggest threat you must get ready
and prepare for your biggest challenge
and i mean biggest challenge to date
every couple of days a giant will emerge
and walk towards your village with the
intent of destroying the sea the big
brazil
you must stop it and take it down
whatever the cost
otherwise it's game over
you can of course play tribes of midgard
completely on your own but
we highly recommend that you bring along
9 friends to thrive together
we cannot wait to share more information
about this ever-growing epic saga in the
weeks to come
in the meantime you can already
pre-order the game right now to earn
exclusive items and be among the first
to defend midgard against ragnarok
because as they say
valhalla can wait
thanks for watching
set sail
at gearbox university it's not all
textbooks and calculators sometimes we
like to kick back and have a little fun
a good sense of humor is of vital
importance if you want to succeed in
these halls here's a list of sensible
wise cracks you might hear when you're
exploring our campus why did the tribe
of midgard cross the road to get to the
oh thor side knock knock who is there
the commando the commando who i don't
know what are you asking me for
welcome to the home world diner our
special today is the dessert of carrot
help i've got fallen and i can't get up
claptrap tiny tina and mad moxie walk
into a bar
wait i think moxie owns the bar so why
would she be walking in she'd already be
there and is tiny tina old enough to
drink maybe it doesn't matter in space
also what's the punchline and how is
claptrap walking in i want to say he
counts as a unicycle okay we'll work on
this before we submit to e3 gearbox
university our comedy school is a
two-year degree
macros thinks the war is over
but our fight has just begun
our duty is to carry the burden of war
or just save the victory
what fun is death when death is the end
of our fun
the darkness has breached reality
it is time my champion
[Music]
we both know how this is going to end
time for your madness to end brother
i was never just your brother
i
am your god
greetings everyone my name is dick hayne
and i'm the senior technical producer at
counter play games first and foremost on
behalf of everyone at cpg and gearbox
alike i want to thank you for being part
of godfall's journey up until this point
it's crazy to think that godfall just
launched in november of last year our
developers have been hard at work ever
since in fact this past february we
launched the massive primal update which
included new content such as additional
rooms and tower of trials primal gear
ascension levels and much much more but
i'm excited to announce today that on
august 10th we will be launching godfall
on the playstation 4. not only that but
owning godfall on the ps4 entitles you
to a free ps5 upgrade and we will
support cross-gen play so ps4 and ps5
users can seamlessly co-op together
and if you've been struggling in the
ascendant tower of trials don't worry
we're adding matchmaking but really
matchmaking and the ps4 edition are just
the tip of the iceberg because we are so
excited to launch our first ever
expansion which we've entitled fire and
darkness
fire and darkness will take players into
the fire realm for the first time ever
where they'll be met with new challenges
enemies bosses trophies cosmetics and so
so much more
but alongside fire and darkness we're
also releasing a free content update
which we're calling the lightbringer
update the main component of the
lightbringer update is a new endgame
loop which we're calling lightbringer in
lightbringer players will fight off the
darkness that threatens appearion and be
rewarded with a new loot type
first loot
cursed loot will challenge the player to
complete particular objectives in order
to lift the curse and awaken them
basically if you thought primal gear was
tough you ain't seen nothing yet and
then of course we want to make fashion
the forefront of god fall so we have
added a huge library of cosmetics to
both the lightbringer update and the
expansion alike all of which can be
unlocked by simply completing objectives
in the game
thank you so much for your time today it
is an honor to be speaking here and i
hope you enjoy the rest of your e3
there's a really unique tone and vibe
and feel to homeworld that hasn't been
emulated since
uh it's not a prequel it's not a
remaster it is homeworld three it is the
next
homeworld we're glad you've chosen
gearbox university for your higher
education endeavors as you engage in
your academic pursuits don't forget to
try out our extracurricular activities
show off your shutterbug talents in the
photography club make lasting
connections in our chapter houses or if
you're a boring person you can always
try out for the debate team we also have
sporting events but try not to party too
hard at the homecoming game or you'll
end up looking like this
be sure to follow us on social media
where you'll occasionally find free
shift codes as well as news and
announcements about our latest
scholastic offerings gearbox university
we can shape your future because
thinking for yourself is hard
now go buy all our games
we're back
i hope you guys had an awesome
presentation from all the gearbox games
and development and gearbox publishing
products coming uh listen uh
i'm standing outside
kevin hart's trailer door i'm just gonna
you guys want to meet him i think i
think i think he wants to meet you guys
let's see let's see
hey kevin you got a minute
ah borderlands fans meet kevin hart how
you guys doing man
pretty pumped up right now to meet you
guys uh randy you should tell them
actually how big i am in person
of how much height i put on for this
role
dude you are freaking awesome like i
don't like i you don't you don't
understand like you're a freaking action
player thank you man this is this is
amazing watching you you know you're
blowing my mind i'm going to say uh i'll
one-up you i'll say it's amazing for me
to have the opportunity to portray the
character involvement of course who
you're very familiar with because this
is your creation um i think the biggest
the best thing is the surprise that you
guys are gonna be in for cause you got
no idea
what i'm doing or how i'm doing or why
i'm doing it you got no idea the level
that came in there you got no idea how
much preparation i decided to put into
this particular character in this role
you got no idea
you got no idea you don't even know
what's under this jacket
omg it's metal
you got no
idea
my job is to come in not only be
prepared but to shock and i think right
now to slug the door you're doing it
i've seen some i've seen some pretty
like it's it's intense it's no one's
ever seen you like this before no i can
honestly say man eli is doing such a
phenomenal job
it's also fun to work with him like he's
working his ass off well everyone's
working their ass absolutely you got an
amazing cast
kate
jamie uh ariana myself flo our director
eli jack black you're putting amazing
people together so shouts out to you
your team and gearbox that's how the
lions get you know for seeing that this
is something that could be phenomenal
shouts out to uh to the world of pandora
pandora knowers
[Music]
that you guys that know and love this
world i promise you you're going to be
in complete all when you see how real we
have made it become uh from a place of
visual you know you're going to believe
that you're in this place with it so wow
you're making me cry man
you my eyes are well enough
thank you man yeah i appreciate you
taking a minute to
introduce yourself to to our fans no
problem i'm going back in here
i'll see you later i've got a weight
room in here just rolling lifts weights
in between tanks you'll know why later
take it easy kevin thanks man holy crap
you guys this is i can't wait for you to
see this movie it won't be long but uh
we still got a lot of work to do we're a
little bit more than halfway done with
production and uh but you know what back
at home at gearbox all the great people
that created this universe that i'm here
representing on behalf of all the talent
and gearbox we're hard at work making
new stuff so
check this out and i'll see you guys
soon cheers everybody
[Music]
thank you
is
[Music]
do
[Music]
so we'll start with the movie stuff
so obviously the borderlands movie sorry
borderlands the movie is uh in
production i think they said during
their vt that they're about halfway done
they have an absolutely
ridiculous cast that is so surprising to
be like kate blanchett they've got uh
jack black obviously kevin hart that we
saw and yet and obviously um what would
you call him eli roth is involved and um
the people who worked on the marvel
movies
that was all right i'm at home
that was definitely ham at home but it's
like
i
i'm not sure why we saw this behind the
scenes stuff where they literally show
like yes queen give us nothing
the whole time it's like i don't
understand why we couldn't have just
held this and had like a bigger
beat later on down the line because we
didn't we didn't see any other costume
we didn't see
we just saw soundstage this is very very
confusing and i it's a weird drip
feeding of information that's
like the worst part of it is superplexed
no one no one got the benefit of
anything there the movie didn't benefit
the game tiny tina's wonderlands did not
benefit at all like they talked about
a couple things and they showed the same
trailer that we saw earlier in the week
twice
and that just left like me thinking what
you have got it doesn't make a good
impression that you've got your own like
platform right now you've got your own
stage to say anything you want about
this spin-off to a video game that's
beloved by so many people you're taking
in an interesting new direction and
you've got literally nothing to say
about it other than it's got wyverns and
goblins in there like wait i could have
i could have told you that it was going
to have weapons and goblins in it if you
didn't tell me like obviously and like
the the uh
the other games like uh the
valhalla one what's it called again i
can't even remember
tribes of midgard
like that that didn't benefit from
anything at all they showed off a
trailer and then had a dude say like yep
you can save
the world but like didn't dig into any
sort of gameplay mechanics like
give give five minutes to that game to
try and sell people on it and then that
had nothing and then it was just it
genuinely felt like we want to have
the movie
showcased in some regard how can we have
enough content to string it all together
and it was like
you've wasted
you've you've played yourself and you've
played the developers
like what's going on here even even
godfather nothing
i mean godfather godfather admittedly
did have like quite a big news beat that
was sort of
quietly sort of revealed there they did
reveal the godfall is gonna be coming to
ps4 so
that's very very interesting like
because godfather was you know one of
the few like proper ps5 exclusives um
for a time i think it was also a pc
right but like in terms of console it
was ps5 and so
that coming to ps4 is great obviously
there are way more ps4s in the world
than there are ps5s that's cool that's a
news story that's worthy of it um
worthy news story though
god fall godfall the game
everyone's playing godfather godfall
coming to ps4 that should not be like
the oh at least they announced that
gothel is coming to ps4 that's
interesting that should not be your
interesting thing to come from your
conference
just shut it i found it i yeah it just
like i mean even at jeff's show the
other day when uh tiny tears wonderlands
was officially unveiled like you had
ashley burch there
it's it's very strange like i don't
understand why you wouldn't you know
bring her back like she's key talent um
obviously it's great that they were
talking to the senior producer on the
game but if you're not letting her
reveal anything about the game then it's
that's a strange
song we've had these gearbox press
conferences that are kind of strange and
meandering there's they've always been
entertaining to a degree though the
thing about this one is it was strange
and meandering and kind of pointless and
it didn't have any randy pitch for doing
magic
like if you're gonna i was if you're
gonna have nothing in your in your
showcase at least i'm gonna have randy
pitchford in it at least have him do
a magic routine that everyone can meme
nothing absolutely nothing just pure
drive the surface of mars this
this showcase there's no water to be
found
unless i mean unless
this was
you know
we've we've been dealing with like
coveted delaying stuff a lot like case
in point all of 2020 and obviously
there's still gonna be ramifications for
people working from home well into 2021
and i think beyond two so maybe this was
just a case of they over committed to a
presentation and then at the end where
it was like the dev teams just kind of
maybe said we're not gonna have this in
time maybe production on the movie move
back because of new um
scheduling stuff to do with the movie or
whatever production schedules shift all
the time and maybe they just were like
we need to focus on getting those done
we're not going to have anything big to
show at this showcase
which is it feels that way to me and
maybe this is just me reading between
the lines because
you know i wanted gearbox to have a
better cooler more noteworthy showing
and so it felt like those interstitials
where you know you had the dad jokes
that were really leaning into sort of
gearbox humor you had the stuff about um
uh what was it borderlands university
like borderlands the science project
that they were doing which is super
super cool
it just feels like maybe they just
didn't have enough time um
but overall we're gonna uh
throw to the esa stream this was our
very very brief post stream for gearbox
uh quickly jordan overall thoughts
on the stream
i
earlier this week i said i wanted to see
how wonderland's was different from
borderlands and they didn't give it to
me i'm disappointed i wanted more
time
yeah i mean like i
i'm more excited about wonderland than i
have been about a gearbox game in a long
time and i'm a fan of borderlands and i
hope that the team behind it gets the
opportunity to show off what's cool
about that game and really sell it
in a way that
doesn't have their thunder stolen by
literally nothing else which is it was a
big like shoot yourself in the leg
moment um i'm sure there's amazing
things and i'm excited to see your game
if you're listening um yeah good luck
all right we'll be back again tomorrow
morning at 9 00 a.m don't forget uh for
our xbox pre-show we're gonna go over to
the esa show right now and then kurt
jordan and phil will be back after that
to wrap up e3 day one catch you soon
you